bonjour messieurs
allons-y justice
si vous êtes là c'est parce que vous
allez mal
[Applaudissements]
parce que vous avez envie d'aller mieux
voilà c'est ici d'ailleurs je le bois de
merde
seuls
les seize mille mots rien n'y a même pas
de réseau je vous assure que mon peut
fonctionner sans vous c'est seulement
quatre jours on va positiver le sien on
est bien la taille
non ça va ça va à ces [ __ ] finale
face à une cote de golf c'est un rôti
d'agneau med a fait avec carottes non
j'essaie de réduire ma consommation de
viande je suivais gad
bon un peu plus vos trucs de pique nique
avant j'en peux plus j'ai jemma lowe
votre esprit mais
je peux
quand une porte se ferme une autre
s'ouvre toujours oui parfois dans la
gueule aussi
savait ce qu'on vit là
on est en train de se tricoter des
souvenirs
qui combine la gueule vous êtes
magnifique
mode cas pour ben allez c'est parti tout
seul il est violent
vous inquiétez pas il va revenir dans
exactement cinq secondes
[Musique]